what do you think about the
UFO sightings so the widespread
experiences that people have and seeing
different phenomena that they sort of
that are mysterious that people project
ideas about whether it's aliens or not
but they can't explain it and there's
pictures and data and then the
government is involved in releasing
footage and all that kind of stuff and
that seems to Captivate the public
imagine it always do I mean you know
there are a number of things that uh
Captivate people especially children
actually dinosaurs and aliens still a
child yeah we are also child at heart
and
um so about UFOs I am a Scientist and
I'm a citizen so I'm going to tell you a
couple of things first I don't mind
talking about that at all because I
think as a scientist this is extremely
interesting because the thing I don't
know I want to learn about it this is
more knowledge so we all know the
statistics about UFOs
95 percent of them are just natural
phenomenon or things that are being
misinterpreted we know that then you
have the two percent that might be
secret programs by whatever government
uh it's out there
another person say is about natural
phenomenon that
we don't know about yet that we cannot
explain and then there is this tiny
percentage that don't fall into all
these categories of thing and I think
that the re the report about the uaps
falls into the same kind of scheme
except that now they have at least some
patterns of speed of other things that
were in the report today we don't know
if these sightings are
part of military program or actual UFOs
I always run into that question because
of course as the Director of the car
second Center at the study Institute I
received a number of emails about the
subject people actually
confused about what the study Institute
is we are not studying UFOs we are
studying we are actually looking for
messages the way I put it you know
usually is that we are studying
extraterrestrial in their natural
habitat yes and and the UFO people are
trying to understand whether they
invaded our aerial space yes so this is
very two very different things and
unfortunately over the years I actually
respect very much people who are trying
to go to the bottom of what UFO are
following some very
scientific ways of doing this they are
very very credible agencies doing this
unfortunately there is a folklore around
UFOs and this has been a huge disservice
to the scientific community and this is
why you have been having that much
pushback for a long time by the
scientific Community because no
Congressman in the world wants to tell
their taxpayer that they are supporting
something that looking for flying
saucers and you know when you see what's
happening it's terrifying and I am
actually
concerned you know about that
relationship that people do between
folklore and real search for
extraterrestrial intelligence
in fact it's been so bad that
until today
there is no government agency that is
actually funding the city search it is a
private funded endeavor
what NASA funds right now which is a
progress is a search for techno
signature which means that when you are
looking at the atmosphere of a planet
you look for some disequilibrium that
could tell you that something is there
but it's not going to found a an
Institute or whatnot that is looking for
messages or or other things like that
does that just have to do with the taboo
associated with the folklores yes and I
think there was a pushback
from the political Arena
decades ago about that at the time where
all the Flying Saucer were coming out uh
and then the city Institute got it
started so
um but now there is more of a
willingness to look at the UAP
UFO uh phenomenon from a scientific
standpoint so much so that the
government is actually seeking some help
from a scientific institution and there
are programs to start looking into those
phenomenon and as a scientist I am
interested what I'm not interested in
again Carl Sagan comes back here I don't
want to believe I want to know and so to
know you have to have a real experiment
you have to have observation and you
have uh things that are done the right
way I don't want to have somebody that
start with what if as a question and
then turns this what if in into the only
argument and the only conclusion there
is you understand but still I think it's
valuable to appreciate the mystery and
not deny the mystery so no the mystery
is there but what I don't want is people
taking advantage of the public and
making money out of folklore well let me
flip that I understand but so there's a
folklore and like the stuff I do Ai and
Robotics for example there's a clear
fear Terminator and movies and all those
kind of stuff you could say that I'm
very concerned about this miscalibrated
uh understanding of the public of what
robots role are in society or you could
see it as a let's use a metaphor of a
wave you can say this giant wave
they'll call folklore is a really bad
idea we need to uh avoid it we need to
hide we need to build dams or you can be
a surfer and ride the wave as a
scientist
to me the fact that people are wondering
about the mystery of UFOs it means
they're wandering no they are but the
thing I I will stop surfing that wave
when it comes back to bite an entire
scientific discipline for science sure
for now the past 60 years
we were not able to raise money from the
government no grants it's a discipline
that has no postdoc of very little
postdoc just because there is a fear of
that folklore on the political Arena
people don't want to be associated with
that because they confuse the two so I
stopped
there and as the Director of the Carl
Sagan Center I am just very happy to see
now that there is a course correction
in the government seeking scientific
investigators for this kind of issues
and hopefully that will write the ship
there I love it I love to see it but I
want and I love her a little
disagreements I'm I'm doing so obviously
respectfully with love and it's it makes
it for a fun conversation but I think
you know just like with surfing a wave
there there's some level of if the more
you resist it the worse it is so I we
didn't resist it yes it didn't come from
us and we paid the price
I just think that
the role of a scientists in part in the
21st century when we talked about social
media it's the direct this sense of
wonder that people have
into a direction of the rigors of
science I think we do that pretty well I
would disagree I don't think Society
does much better but there's other
places in science where the sexual life
is fair it fairly easy place to you know
draw The Wonder of people yes because
it's a profound question that pretty
much everybody has but I think I just
want to highlight the fact that I think
a lot of scientists my colleagues
friends think that all you need to do is
science
all you need to do is this the the
scientific process the peer review
process the the data and so on but I
think communication is actually a
fundamental part of the process
um because it has to do with funding but
also has to do like where where a bunch
of humans trying to ask big questions
trying to figure this whole puzzle out
and nobody agree we do have more Public
Presentation at The Institute than
peer-reviewed articles and believe me we
have a lot of peer-reviewed Articles so
our scientists are out there and they
are sharing The Wonder of discoveries
and it's so easy these days I mean there
is not one day tell me about writing a
book right now about the search for life
in the universe I mean it's almost every
single day I had to correct something in
the chapters I was writing